let's consider a very simple example of
a runner in which our position function
X of T is given as a quadratic function
in time it will be a constant B times T
squared here B is a constant now it's
always important in SI units to consider
what the units of this constant is
because the position function is
measured in meters and time is measured
in seconds B is a constant and it has
units of meters per second squared and
there's an example of a runner and let's
make a plot of that position function so
we're going to plot X of T as a function
of time B here let's make be a positive
constant and so our function looks
something like that now the velocity
component of the velocity remember D of
T is given by DX DT of this function and
the derivative of a polynomial T squared
is very simple that's just simply 2 B
times T again let's look at our units
because B has the units of meters per
second squared and we're multiplying
that by second we have the units of
velocity in SI units as meters per
second now 2 let's plot that function
notice this is a linear function and so
if I plotted underneath here the
velocity as a function of time its
starts off with a 0 slope remember we're
looking our velocity at any given time
corresponds to the slope of the tangent
line to the position function and you
can see that slope is increasing now you
wouldn't know from this graph but if you
did plot T squared it's increasing
linearly and so our velocity function
the initial slope is zero at T equals
zero and it's increasing linearly in
time so we'll just draw that as some
linear function and the slope here
of this function will be now the
acceleration so a of T is the derivative
of the component of the velocity
function as a function of time and this
derivative is quite easy it's just
simply to be now notice those have the
units of meters per second squared we
saw our units for acceleration when we
again look at the slope notice that at
every single point the slope of the
velocity as a function of time is a
constant the slope here is just equal to
2b and so now if we plotted our
acceleration function we have this point
to be and every single point has the
same value of acceleration so here the
acceleration is an example of constant
acceleration and this is our simplest
case notice we started with a position
function we differentiate to get the
component of the velocity and to get the
component of the acceleration so this is
a very simple model for a runner whose
increasing speed linearly accelerating
at a constant rate